we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the Eggman
almost brought to tears he reported in
this voicemail take a listen to this
Dave Congress gave Jeff Sessions zero
dollars to go against medical marijuana
legal marijuana that story it it almost
made me cry he filled me with such hope
you saved it for the after show yeah
not fair oh my god leave read alone Jeff
Sessions please shallow brother yeah we
debt was a bonus show story but we
teased it on the regular show and yes
the federal government has said we're
not giving arms our Congress has said
we're not giving Jeff Sessions money to
prosecute the war on drugs against
marijuana in states that have legalized
medical marijuana
Eggman's call here kind of reminds me of
that viral YouTube video ten years ago
of the person shouting leave Britney
Alone I think that's what it was a
reference to okay and by the way Chris
Crocker the kid from the lead britney
alone video big fan of the david pakman
show gonna say i was thinking that maybe
he was on the david pakman show you
never been on no no he's a big big
really now do you pronounce it Eggman i
like that so it's like i'm that it's
like a like steve Eggman or something
like that hackman the Eggman yeah
because you don't pronounce your name
pac-man no i don't and it's any when
people do it is annoying so Eggman I
like it yeah I like it so the Eggman may
be known going forward as speed Eggman
although his first name is not even
Steve but it's okay it has a nice ring
to it maybe his first name is Edmund
equity that you had yeah I like that I
like that but anyway if the Eggman is
almost brought to tears then you know
that it's a major major story on the
bonus show today the home foreclosure
rate is down 85 percent over the last
eight years we'll talk about why Flint
Michigan is putting 8,000 people on
notice for tax liens for unpaid water
bills of course water that is riddled
with lead and a new study indicates that
cats actually seem to like people after
all and we will get Pat's reaction to
this explosive and breaking story and we
will find out how if at all this effects
feelings about his own cat ownership
about his outdoor cat which is likely
responsible for the deaths of thousands
upon thousands of migratory birds and
about pet ownership in general but we'll
talk about that on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership is how you
sign up for membership and get instant
access to the bonus show you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 if you want also
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
make pledges of as little as one dollar
per month check it out